this is a special concert for me
obviously because it was the first one
as as a music director and it was live
on television and the way the rehearsal
schedule when we didn't have that much
time to prepare it so we were not as
played into the program as as I would
ideally want to be I'm not making
excuses of the saying that this was the
situation so when I went out on onstage
I was in a way trying to skip a step I I
am I love the experience of playing a
piece over and over on tour because it
does improve it develops it matures and
we had a wonderful experience doing that
in January and februari i did a tour
with the orchestra this was several
months after the the opening and one of
the pieces we played was the second
symphony of sibelius and I like to keep
working and I like to keep them defining
and perfecting things and when we
finally came to back to New York and
plated in kearny Hall it really was
possible to give a performance that was
based on comfort and experience this one
we
hadn't played and I tried in my mind to
kind of play a Mental Trick and attend
that all that developments had happened
and sometimes that actually works very
well and with a norstra liking your
harmonic that can really deliver in the
moment and be poised and absolutely step
up to the plate it can work for me
emotionally I was also trying to stay
calm I don't really get nervous for for
concerts some people find that
interesting to hear they think oh do you
get nervous in concerts and I don't so
much get nervous and even in this
concert which was you know highly
scrutinized and and important being the
first one and all I wasn't so nervous
but I was at the same time trying to
make sure that I was calm and I wasn't
taking tempos too fast sometimes when
you're not aware of it if you're keyed
up and if you know the stakes are high
the tempos tend to come out faster so i
was trying to to really just settle down
and make as expressive a case for the
music as i can and the Berlioz is is a
great piece as far as that goes it's a
great piece on by any measure but it's
so colorful and it has a kind of
combination I think you know some people
called Berlioz the kind of most German
of the French composers and and I find
that actually interesting in Varian and
rather telling because he he has the
kind of impressionistic pastel refined
quality of sound in his music and I
think you hear that right at the
beginning and that's one of the one of
the excerpts that that we've we've just
looked at it's it starts out with this
amazing lightness and delicacy you can
imagine a kind of Monet painting where
the colors kind of bleed into each other
and it's just very veiled and lovely and
then they're their moments in the in the
in the peace where there has to be an
incredible precision and a
macdrive and and they're very few
composers who I think really encompass
encompass this incredible range of both
rhythmic precision with tonal fantasy
and as a conductor you try to show the
time as clearly as possible but there
are moments in this piece where it
doesn't work simply to be precise you
have to embody the the Evanescence of
the sound the kind of lightness of
texture and it's very interesting how
just the simple quality of your body if
you hold your hands like this or if you
relax them it affects the sound
instantly the players read that and they
sympathetically create that kind of
sound so I find it very difficult i
think all conductors find it difficult
to have the right kind of connection and
horizontal lightness in the sound while
at the same time determining points
along the way that are the tempo that's
to me the challenge of Berlioz and
really what I was trying to accomplish
is to have both sides of his music